[Musique]
je pense que ce qui est très fort et
d'ailleurs c'est ce qui a traversé les
temps puisque c'est une pièce quand je
l'pr locage à à créé dans les années 90
donc c'est une pièce qui date et C pièce
traverse les temps et il reste actuel et
apporte aussi quelque chose puisque il a
mis quand même un il a rajouté au à la
au texte de Shakespeare cette
cette opposition pas opposition mais ces
deux classes
[Musique]
sociales la famille des juliettes qui
qui est une famille des pouvoirs
d'autorité des
contrôles milicienne on va dire et la
classe sociale des Roméo une classe
pauvre opprimée et malheureusement c'est
une thématique qui a voilà qui est
aujourd'hui aussi
d'actualité
en fait quand on lit Roméo Juliet il y a
cette opposition entre les familles mais
c'est pas peut-être très clair pourquoi
là en plus il a il a comment dire faire
ressortir cette raison qui voilà
qui qui est très importante
[Musique]
aujourd'hui
c'est un décor assez futuriste et
assez je pense que on est on rentre tout
de suite dans le
décor c'est une pièce très forte
puisqu'il y a 24 danseurs sur scène
euh et on vit cette spectacle comme si
on était dedans et je pense que c'est le
décor de villal qui qui qui nous
soumerge dans cette ambiance c'est et la
force des danseurs donc on se sent tout
de suite dedans c'est comme si on était
sur scène avec les
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
danseurs magique parce que c'est une
pièce qui n'a pas vieilli des autres
pièces bon parfois il faut les réadapter
et ce mais c'est là vous allez voir la
pièce telle que qu'il l'a créé avec le
même décor la même musique et les même
mouvement et elle a pas
vieilli
[Musique]